growing up in Austin Texas this young QV
had the same dream every young player in
that great state had to Sunday play
college football Purdue depend on to be
selected by the Chargers with the first
pick of the second round of the 2009
ground which is still technically the
second round after reaching the Pro Bowl
in San Diego went on to New Orleans
where I lent the Saints to a Super Bowl
victory in the coming years expected to
challenge several time NFL records but
let's face it that's what happens when
you for a very very long time please
welcome
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
came in thrown passes here all right you
see buddy good to see you
you threw a pass to a Falcons yeah he
was the first one to throw his hands up
you know so I appreciate his enthusiasm
but then I realized that it's a founder
Maddy I take it back you know first of
all thanks for coming in because I know
that this has been some trying times
here yeah yeah now I can be your doctor
Phil if you want me to this is a
counseling session yeah you can you can
lie down if you want to what was the
conversation like when you went home
after the loss um first off I mean
listen we had a bunch of a bunch of
family and friends in town obviously for
the game and so just spend time with
them but who breaks the ice when you get
home
well you know we sat around and watched
the AFC Championship game
you know after it really caught really
the fourth quarter of it you know by the
time we got out of locker room and I
mean here's the thing the first thing I
did after the game was go upstairs see
my family and take my kids down the
field and let them play because that's
what we do after every game so why
should this be any different you know
it's kind of the thrill of their week
yeah they have the chance to do that so
just threw balls and my kids on the
superdome turf and you know was was
their holder as they kick extra points
and are you in Janelle I was dad I was
dad yeah yeah AM am I or was I what were
you in denial right after yeah probably
a little bit you know obviously just the
the sense of shock I mean not obviously
that's not not what we expected to
happen you know we expected to be
celebrating and getting ready to go the
Superbowl but you know it was it was
tough you know it takes you it takes you
a while and and it it took me a good
part of all of last week you know just
to just to try to get some closure on
the game and you know you go back and
you just play it over and over in your
mind I mean bottom line is obviously we
know the the caller the no call
that you know could have resulted in us
you know being here but you know I like
to think about the things that I can
control and that is something we can't
control so we can't really worry about
it I I feel I feel like there were were
things that happen prior to that moment
and then even after that moment that you
know we did control young could have
gotten us in a position to to be here
and so that's what I do for any for any
loss for that matter not just that one
is you play the game over in your mind
you you make those plays that maybe you
didn't make and and that's how you
correct that's how you correct the
situation and then you move on
unfortunately there's no other game to
move on to right it's it's the finality
of the season
did you hear from the Commissioner
personally no I did not and I'm not
aware of anybody else in our theme who
did but didn't listen there a message
that was sent that he did contact the
sinks supposedly not yes I know I think
he spoke to our owner mrs. gilben s'en
you know I think Shawn had a
conversation with them know calm a brief
one know Ben but but other than that no
I haven't spoken any players that spoke
to him take us through the play what's
the play called and then when do you
realize you're seeing something and then
you're trying to plead your case to
somebody
ironically the play was actually it was
a it was kind of a hurry-up play a
little a little bit of a misdirection to
try to confuse the Rams defense
ironically the play was called Buckhead
there was a popular part of Atlanta as
it was a play that was hopefully going
to get us to Atlanta right so you know I
throw the ball realizing they're a bit
out of position and as as Nikhil Roby
number 23 they're their nickel
corner was kind of scrambling to get to
his responsibilities which was Tommy Lee
Lewis coming out of the backfield and
I'm he even said in his interview you
know he was trying to protect a
touchdown right and you know so there's
a helmet helmet he was early you know so
two penalties could have been called on
the play
you see when he turns around that he's
waiting for a flag to be thrown and then
after five seconds he realizes it's not
and then they all get excited but do you
say anything to the official or pall
towards the jumbotron no no I a lot of
that was happening on our side line
obviously Sean you know if you see the
camera angle of our sideline you see
everybody waiting for the call right and
then when it doesn't happen it's it's
this eruption and Sean goes down there
and pleads this case but you even see
the official reach for the flag and then
but I wonder about this drew now I've
said this earlier in the week that you
had these all-star crews whereas if you
had the team that is usually there
calling games together it feels like
you're gonna trust me to come over and
say hey we need to huddle up I think you
may have made a mistake there but if you
do an all-star officiating crew they're
not used to doing this and I wonder if
it's a team together that they would
have actually huddled up because you I'm
sure you could hear the helmet-to-helmet
it was very obvious that there was at
least two penalties on that play and it
it felt like somebody may you've been on
place where there's three flags for one
penalty so why why can't you have these
officials go wait wait hold up hold up I
think we may have missed one here yeah
that makes a lot of sense
okay that makes a lot of sense listen we
we recognize that throughout the course
of a game
there's there's there's there's
questionable calls that are always made
there's calls that are missed
there's bangbang plays where man it just
happened so fast I'm not sure and maybe
some officials err on the side of I'm
gonna throw the flag and then others are
now I'm gonna let them play um you know
each officiating crew has different
tendencies and those are things that we
talk about but to your point when you
get to the playoffs you do have these
all-star officiating crews and and to me
that doesn't make any sense
you know I understand you're trying to
reward you know these these crews these
officials for good performances
throughout the ceiling listen they're
graded yeah so to speak on their
performances just like we are right and
then that results in the playoff games
that you're able to officiate or the
Super Bowls that you're able to
officiate but at the end of the day a
crew develops a rapport with one another
and they know how to work together they
know how to solve those types of
problems and it would make a lot more
sense to keep those crews together to
keep it consistent and I don't want to
change the system because of one bad
call and like you know takes one bad
call and all of a sudden we want to
change over time because you know
mahomes didn't get the ball in overtime
in the Patriots get to go to the Super
Bowl right right if Kansas City's scored
and the Patriots don't get to go nobody
says hey let's revamp revamp overtime
you got overtime worked in your game you
guys got the ball the Rams played good
defense got the ball and then won the
game as far as replaying these I don't
know how we could do this do you have
any suggestions on how we could have
aside from making the correct call
change that call in the moment going
forward listen it's it's it's difficult
you know look at the progression though
of just instant replay for example right
you know at some point we said all right
we need to start reviewing some of these
game-changing type plays they also call
it turnovers right or it was hey let's
give coaches the opportunity to throw a
red flag to have a play challenge that
you know so that we can all get it right
you know do they at some point those
challenges went to the booth right it's
okay inside of two minutes no it's not
the coaches challenge it's gonna be New
York you know looking at these plays you
know from the hub and and and making
sure that you know all touchdown plays
or reviews all turnover plays are
reviewed well do you start doing that
with certain types of penalties you
can't do them with all it's dangerous it
is it is because I maybe if I look at
the helmet the helmet I see one of your
linemen holding
and then what do you do right right you
know and arguably you could call holding
on every play yes in the NFL whether it
be a DB or whether it be a yeah
alignment or somebody else yeah you know
you know I said this to with Saints fans
you can't you you can't let this stay
with you could you want to and you're
angry and you don't know who you're
angry at because you know I'm not I
wouldn't be angry at the commissioner
like you know like I don't know I mean
no it wasn't it was it was the it's it's
human it's human error you know I mean
there's there's the officials have an
extremely tough job what but what would
you say to the commissioner right now
well I think that we all recognize that
being in that bat in that position you
are you are the face of the league and
and you have the responsibility to come
out and address issues when they come
about and I would say that on Monday or
Tuesday after that game we all deserved
a response of some kind and at the end
of the day that could have been listen
we play an imperfect game there are
mistakes made in looking at the film
that that appeared to be an obvious pass
interference and a helmet to helmet foul
unfortunately it was not called it's
it's it's really unfortunate and yet you
know that's that's something we're gonna
strive to make sure that it doesn't
happen or strive to make sure the
officials are making the best calls that
they possibly can right yeah I mean
that's that plain and simple
right I mean do I really want to be in a
position talking about this over and
over again no but I have to stand up and
do it because I have to represent my
team represent the Who Dat nation and
and that's my responsibility
so if commissioners responsibility to do
the same thing and yet we don't hear a
peep for ten days and it's because he
has to do it now because he's at the
Super Bowl and he does his annual press
conference that's right he doesn't come
on their show drew
yeah he doesn't he doesn't come on there
she go other than that how's life my
kids my wife
everything is everything's great besides
why did your helmet did you boys cry
yeah they did they did and what do you
say cuz you're you're always good with
teachable moment I think that yeah I
think they cried because my my wife had
my wife had promised my ten-year-old
that he could get a cell phone if we
went to Super Bowl there they are
invested right they're invested in in
what Dad does in and in our team and
obviously it was listen if you can just
take a step back and reflect on the
season it was it was a great season and
so much to be proud of and I love our
team I love the way we came together we
had so much fun probably had more fun
playing football this year than I ever
have and so when do you start prepping
for next season well in some ways that's
already started but there is this
necessary period of time where it's
called the cooling-off period you know
or just the recharge the battery we use
will you change the name of the play
buckhead or will you still have but
that'll go away we had we have crazy
names because next year's in Miami so I
don't know if we want to change it to
yeah well we'll come up with little
South Beach South Beach Devils tell I
can almost guarantee we'll have next
year there's no chance you're retiring
right no ok good if you had one if you
want a Super Bowl I don't know I don't
think so ok because and I hate doing
that because we're trying to push Brady
out it feels like like hey when are you
retiring and I'm thinking this will
never happen again this run of a
quarterback will never happen again
where you have this many Super Bowls
it's so hard with free agent I mean you
know it you you you got to win one yeah
I mean he's kind of hoarding he's a
hoarder he's a Super Bowl hoarder is
what Brady is yeah it's it's it's truly
remarkable what what he's been able to
accomplish what their team
been able to accomplish in just the run
that they've they've had over the last
two decades it's been remarkable I know
that it you know you know that that lost
hurts but I don't know if Biofreeze
takes away that pain that's called a
segue into the product to talk about so
Biofreeze which i use on my neck every
day do you yes that's right it's great
number one topical pain reliever is it
getting you ready for for practice and
games like this yes because I told Deion
Sanders yesterday now he's known as
prime time and I'm daytime so that's
that's sort of my alter ego
so when daytime shows up you know I
might have some bio freeze when I'm
gonna use the golf simulator
yes little bio freeze helps out yeah
absolutely yeah before and after yes
yeah what do you use it for get ready
for practice get ready for training it's
it's great for sore muscles obviously
gets me puts me in a position I think in
a mindset to that I can get out there
and get my work done and played a
high-level Biofreeze the number one
clinically recommended topical pain
relief product go to Biofreeze dot-com
to learn more I did notice and I haven't
seen too many there was a there's a
Saints fan in here and that's that
little boy right there
I think it'd be kind of nice if maybe
you would have made sense I walked in
and thrown the book thrown the ball to
Michael Thomas yeah sitting in the front
row would you like to come up and get a
hug from Drew Brees here
hug it out Nancy thing
oh these same shoes and guess who gave
them to me Michael Thomas oh that's a
throwback well alright we're here I
gotta throw oh you're gonna go okay yeah
you're gonna have to go deep though
okay a little one-hander not too deep
not too far all right we ready into the
into the lawn chair there that's good
hey during the during the live look in
would you uh would you smoke McLovin
with a couple of passes I would be happy
to tradition unlike any other I'm big
I'm big on tradition um do you have
anything to say about drew cuz you
normally taunt these quarterbacks here
so just tread tread softly here well I
don't think I need to say tell him what
you said to Eli oh I told you I just
just pretend I'm an Eagles defensive
back and try to but after you talked
about the bad call for ten minutes he
seems plenty angry I don't think I need
to the mix alright we'll come back drew
if you're watching on audience Channel
239 DirecTV the NBC Sports Network drool
pummel McLovin with a couple of tosses
thanks for coming by as always but good
to see you see you even under these
circumstances for more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]